previously if you feel like you got to
make like a Western omelet or something
oh this coffee smells like look it's a
hard and fast rule TV if you can't get
your opening credits out of the way in
60 seconds you will get sint we send
that incredible Game of Thrones opening
for going too long you really think
American Gods is getting away with over
100 seconds of this also astronaut Jesus
they were hungry of course a very first
word of this show is both narration and
pronoun gaming and American Gods is
letting us know right off the bat it
doesn't give a kanesha's rat's ass about
maintaining any kind of coherence even a
salad wouldn't do I'm not sure exactly
what year this part is sitting but going
to go with the year uh no one knew what
the salad was complete and utter
nonsense worth a sin of course but still
awesome
did they really need to set up this
elaborate sand contraption to see if the
wind was blowing not that any of this
actually matters because we are still
firmly in the abstract story that has
nothing to do with our main characters
portion of the episode which I'm now
thinking might be a majority of this
gods forsaken show there are so many
competitions where shirts and skins
makes complete sense
basketball backyard football wet t-shirt
contests but murder tournament is not
one of them this war footage is so
over-the-top gory that I've blurred the
entire screen but just know that this
battle indicates that all humans are
haemoglobin water balloons just waiting
to be popped and I do not believe that
is accurate and of course it's
intentional and yes it's a stylized
choice but maybe I'm just sending it
because it's gross I'm not even sure I
want to reckon with my own mortality
today benching without an appropriately
attentive spotter I don't believe in
anything I can't see like the point of
this show for instance has a way of
trying to keep you in prison it's very
apparent that Justin Tucker went to the
Brad Pitt school of 12 monkeying things
for this performance
smells snow in case you're wondering
what kind of show American Gods is it's
exactly the kind of show that goes
directly from a makeshift noose metaphor
to the phrase I smell snow and then
flips you the bird if you ask it for any
kind of explanation game of bones
firk slap I'm saying do not piss off
those [ __ ] in airports sure it's
convenient that he remembered this
random conversation with Loki but it's
even stranger that they had a
conversation about airport etiquette in
the
what I offer you the one from my beak
and you look at me like a true mom is
this a bad thing my dad did the same
thing all the time
not the offering worms part more than my
mom part what's today Wednesday hmm
today's my day this conversation has
been going on for over two minutes and
will continue for over three more so if
long drawn-out abstract word salad as
you think welcome to your new favorite
show if not welcome to team this I'll
give you five guesses which team I'm on
mister Wednesday asked the flight
attended to get shadow a Jack and Coke
that is either straight up Jack or
straight up coat but there is no way
both ingredients made it into the
tumbler sometimes I feel like premium
cable is the place where creators go
when they are tired of anyone telling
them they're pretentious slow motion
Buffalo with fire shooting I scene might
need to be cut in the interest of time
and context and what the hell show show
reluctantly admits what it's doing to
the audience with a constant cacophony
of conceptual codswallop
[Music]
oh I've only been on three other dates
from the computer I don't think I have
the talent for it well considering not
Bill Murray calls it the computer I tend
to agree ever gotten in touch for free
see now on the bottom would be great at
TV since way to me like a meal God your
God and he does and then she swallows
him with her vagina for the next three
minutes are you not entertained also I
think I finally understand what the
vagina monologues are about despite the
show giving its best shot at obscuring
any kind of cohesive storyline I'm
picking up that certain characters or
gods or something but serious face
McCrum person here and doesn't know this
and that coin just disappeared into thin
air
why is he not freaking out right now I
told you I'm a leprechaun but don't come
from Moscow Russia in case you confused
it with or Moscow Idaho for that matter
it beat me to it to know who yes well I
really yes I'm not even sure I know who
I am anymore Southern Comfort and coke
for you there's an odd reliance on
various Bourbons and cokes in the show
I'm not sure there's deeper meaning in
that or gods just having super boring
tastes and beverages is it not to adapt
abstract sci-fi religious novels into
long-form TV shows cuz I think it should
be that I was gonna say this shows weird
but weird was like leave me out of this
man I don't even get this seriously
American Gods makes the show Legion look
like a time-life docu-series American
Gods Rock III she died with my husband
their mouth is a literal case of burying
the lede also I know the congregation is
singing at all but I'm pretty sure most
everyone can hear them having this
conversation at full volume Dee's Audrey
didn't anyone tell you to use your
indoor voice when discussing a friend's
wife's fatal automobile fellatio affair
with your husband dad wins this may say
more about me than the show but Audrey
is easily my favorite character so far
and I'm Fran I [ __ ] for a [ __ ]
right here I guess yes was it the part
of the Bible that Jules conveniently
leaves out when he's quoting Ezekiel
25:17 this show is 37 percent gold coin
they are consigned to the dumpster now
if we have reprogrammed Virata
the scene is like the perfect mix of the
matrix and the Wiz and I honestly have
zero clue
a good or bad thing look I know
everything in the show is very
conceptual and strange and confusing
right now thankfully it has a full
season to bring things together so that
it makes some sense and mean something
important I'm not sure to happen the
worst thing about prison was was the
Dementors there must be a con like me
and every prison in America I'm the guy
who can get it for you cigarettes a bag
of reefer if that's your thing how would
you like to have someone come along and
pick something off of you I tell you
something right now I know there and
that was an error it's like something
was wearing air
[Music]
do you have time to improve your life do
you have precisely 30 seconds forward
from Accutron watches mean that is how
this business works
Ruth meant rice you have to like how
they ever tend to like it until you
don't have to anymore